so we have the we have the story out of
berlin that i think is is a good segue
berliner's vote to expropriate large
landlords in non-binding referendum
non-binding okay i don't know if that
really means anything's going to be
accomplished but they do say in the
reuters article that
they say
campaigners hope the city will take
control of some 240 000 apartments that
is to say they probably won't but you
have people in berlin
who are voting that these big companies
that own i think it's 550 000 department
build apartment units
lose control of that and they the public
gains control of it
and the way i see it is it doesn't
matter if it's the private sector or the
public sector
when power is centralized you will get
tyranny so what we've been seeing in the
u.s is like that blackrock fiasco i
don't know if you saw a lot about it
this large these large private
investment firms buying up all the
houses
offering up insane sums of money like
there'll be a 200 000 house and a family
will be like we'll pay 200 and then some
firm will come in and say we'll do 230
because we can and we're rich and we
know the value is going to go up because
we're buying it all
you get to that point you're like okay
these these massive out-of-control
private entities need to have some kind
of regulation or anti-trust
on the other hand
what you see instead is that in berlin
they're like the government should take
all of them replacing one centralized
authority with another
so i don't know i thought this was
interesting for you especially being you
know a mises institute economist
how would what's your view on dealing
with massive out-of-control private
organizations that are seizing the
commons versus you know the left
solution which is government
sure so and you have that key phrase
there even out of control so probably if
you would ask me that 20 years ago i
would have said oh well in a free market
it's good that a private corporation if
they buy it it's not in their interest
to buy it if the price is going to crash
later because then they lose money so
they only buy it if they think it's
going to go up and then that you know
rationally allocates housing to the
highest bidder and
and that would all be true so long as
they respected property rights and there
was no you know
bailouts of then when they get caught
with their pants down and but as we see
in practice that isn't what happened
like you know the housing boom years you
could say of a lot of those comp those
investors why why are they making such
crazy you know why are banks giving
loans to people that they know you know
they call them liar loans they knew some
of those mortgages that they were going
to people who lied on the application
where and when you push it ultimately
it's largely because you know they they
knew they were going to get bailed out
that oh greenspan and then bernanke he
wouldn't let the whole system go down
and so there were things like that in
place so i
agree with you in the real world the
problem with big companies doing that is
because it's not just promoting
efficiency because if they make a
mistake a lot of times taxpayers have to
bail them out or the federal reserve and
so
yeah you're right the way to solve that
problem is not to then empower the
government even more because they're
ultimately the ones that you know keep
that corrupt system in place yeah that's
what's funny it's like uh we were
talking about this in the previous
segment that the government comes in and
says we're gonna fire all the nurses oh
no what do we do well i guess we'll send
in the national guard it's like what you
chose to do all of those things so you
destroy the economy then say here's my
solutions like you punch the guy in the
face and not from the first aid kit it's
like no no that's not acceptable you
can't do that
and in this capacity
you get these uh i can't speak for for
germany but in the u.s my understanding
was that a lot of these large investment
firms were getting bank loans and
government funding and fed dollars were
buying up the property and their
attitude was like we don't care we'll
get bailed out if it screws up so we're
stealing from you no matter what
right right exactly so yeah in a you
know in a genuine free market
i would have no problem in principle
with them doing that because the only
reason they would buy it is if they
think the price is going to go higher
and it's in their interest to not be
consistently wrong about that and if the
price does go higher then they did a
service by you know reserving that for
the person who wanted it more down the
road but you're right but what do you
what do you do if one company
owns 80 of the property and the more
like so the more property they own the
more profit they generate the more
property they buy until eventually one
company owns every like all the houses
in a city or something
okay so
again so long as they're not violating
contracts they're not you know stealing
from people or whether you know that
they're just buying and then they're
only
they're respecting you know the title
that they actually acquired legitimately
the only way they could capture such
market share is if somehow they're out
competing
all the all the other you know
speculators and housing developers who
are trying to do that so like back in
the day the reason rockefeller got so
big was he genuinely came up with
efficiencies and delivered kerosene and
you know patrolling lower prices and so
then later you know you people could
argue they did stuff with their money
that they shouldn't have that wasn't a
market outcome but originally that's how
he beat his competitor so per se i don't
have a problem with that so if some
company
just starts taking over because you know
they're really good at saying no this
property is going to go up and they have
a better eye for real estate you know i
wouldn't want them to stop doing that
but yeah i mean
certainly at some point
you just have a multi-billion dollar
fund saying i don't care if it goes up
i'll buy it anyway because i can because
it doesn't affect our bottom line and
the more property i have the better and
in fact you know
once they control a substantive portion
of the market can't they then manipulate
the market like would there be a would
there need to be a point at which the
government can do something
uh so i would reject the idea that at
some point they don't care like i don't
think warren buffett buys stocks and i
don't care whether they go up or down
because i'm so rich now you're right he
might be able because he's so big now to
do things like the fear in fact that
he's you know likes a stock that might
make the price go up and so that does
kind of change you know the analysis
it's it's it's it's definitely true they
don't care it's not that they don't care
about like like i'm saying they're like
oh no i'm gonna lose money but don't
care it's mostly that they're like look
if i can afford to buy 10 houses
yeah one of them might go down but
whatever you know like i'm going to
diversify i'm going to buy as much as i
can and hope that overall out of out of
my ten houses six gaining value and if
the four that go down hopefully the
gains outweigh the losses
so then you'll end up with someone
saying you know what this might be a
risky buy
but i can handle the risk because i've
got such massive wealth from all the
property i own already i can take the
risk a regular person can't do that so
then you end up with an organization
that can come in and say
200 thousand dollar house for this
middle class working you know this
working family i'll give you 210 and
then the seller is going to be like
210's better for me but then what
happens when the middle class doesn't
own any wealth they can't transfer
anything to their kids you end up with
like chinese style state communism
so so i i suppose you know to go back
you had asked me you know at some point
is it justified for the state to come in
and so i guess what i would say is i
mean we can quibble about you know
scenarios where you know even i might
say yeah i don't that makes me
uncomfortable but to me you don't make
things better by saying let's have you
know those people in washington because
we can trust them to do the right thing
and i know you're not saying that but
you know the same people that are doing
all the stuff that we're talking about
with the national guard and the you know
vaccine mandates and whatnot they're not
going to come in and all of a sudden be
on their best behavior when it comes to
regulating the housing sector like
they're again they're the ones who were
behind the bailouts in the first place
i'm saying like you know is anti-trust
feasible you know the problem i see with
the berlin thing is like the government
just taking the houses is the same
problem as the corporations having the
houses the only difference is who you're
yelling at but what if they said hey you
know we're gonna we're gonna put a limit
on how much property you can own
or something like that or or perhaps
it's like
you're a special case you are the one
company that owns sixty percent of the
properties we think that's too much so
we're gonna we're gonna anti-trust
you're gonna break you up like what's
your thoughts on that
so uh tom delorenzo has done a lot of
good stuff on this people want to look
him up on anti-trust um so i don't have
this ticks off the top of my head but i
think it's true that in the vast
majority of actual anti-trust lawsuits
are brought by the competitors of like
the dominant firm so it's not you know
some disinterested
civic rights organization you know guys
that are you know just doing this and
they're they're getting money from
contributors or something around the
country it's the competitors who try to
bring them down and also
what there were plenty of cases where
companies were viewed as untouchable you
know behemoths that then just collect
like ibm there was a period where they
just dominate and no one who would ever
touch ibm and then microsoft came along
and who could possibly touch microsoft
then google can no one can touch google
you know what i'm saying and so
a lot of times like the the stuff gets
hung up in the antitrust lawsuit and the
company loses market share just because
of market force i mean to be fair those
examples are just escalating tyranny
though you know ibm was making computers
people use computers like that's a great
utility microsoft came along and then
things started to get a little shady
with how they were running their
business apple comes along similar
things and now at the point where google
is just overtly evil and
uh censoring news censoring
conversations stopping regular people
from being able to have conversations
it's to the point where google got so
powerful that
no one can even rise up to challenge
them because if you're a politician or
uh the misense is a good example
wikipedia says you guys are you know it
smears you in ridiculous ways we're at
the point where these institutions have
become so powerful and untouchable
that they can outright just destroy
anyone who would speak up against them
to stop them from abusing power
you know so my view is
i i think
we definitely i definitely lean more
towards freedom and everything but i
would say i'm rather centrist in the
economic scale simply because
while i don't think the government
owning land is going to improve things
for the working class
i think centralization of authority and
power regardless of whether it's
government or corporation is a bad thing
and so how do you descend how do you
break that apart and decentralize it
especially when you know look google is
untouchable and as you said many of
these untouchables have have waned i
mean microsoft is still there and bill
gates is buying up all the farmland so
he's certainly retained all that power
then you've got apple which did a really
great job of rebranding unix and selling
it back to people for for well let's be
real ian unix was open source right it
is open source so he brands he takes the
unix he brands it and then and makes it
makes it private sells it for a massive
profit
convince a bunch of people that shiny is
better and then i have to deal with
people who don't know how to use basic
you know functions on a pc or or run you
know basic programs because they're
using you know iphones and stuff no
offense to the iphone and apple users
i'm not a fan and now you're at the
point where once all that stuff keeps
happening now you get google and
google's got its tentacles in everything
to the point where
you're a
conservative talk show host
and they delete your video because you
cited the cdc that's steven crowder so
now if you can't even speak up against
them in any meaningful way oh of course
we can say google's bad like on this
show but what if you actually want to
challenge their goals and agendas or
something that might affect their their
profits all of a sudden now they're
coming after you they're going to censor
you now you can't even do anything to to
stop it i'm seeing now that unix might
actually be closed source and the linus
torvald
reverse engineered it and created linux
which is open source i don't know i
thought it was open source okay my my
info on that apple stuff is probably
that's kind of big apologies apple
thanks guys so yeah i
i definitely agree with you that what
google's doing right now
isn't is you know they're not living up
to their model right uh well they got
rid of that model
it's alphabet it's good they own google
right right that is like crazy
technology overtly evil
quantum computing they're gonna they're
gonna
i mean
we live under the boot of zuckerberg and
and alphabet you know bill gates yeah so
i i do think that you know 30 40 years
from now it's not just going to be
politicians that we're going to think
that the humans of that era are going to
think are the ones like running the
world it will be like a fusion of
big you know billion multi-billion
dollar corporations and then powerful
states and it'll be more of a hybrid
thing
and that will be considered like the you
know the center of oppression china's
style
capitalism or communism or sure state
common i don't know whatever term you
want to use yeah so that thing
all i would say though is the way to
slow the movement towards that is not to
give you know the ant the department of
justice more power to break up companies
you know so it's a modest point that i'm
making i'm i'm more just you know saying
right this is not the path but so
i've been thinking a lot that politics
is not what we think it is anymore it's
not democrats republicans i mentioned
this before the show that's the skin
suit of politics politics now is
computer software code it's deciding
what we see how we behave who we
interact with so we need to rewrite the
code if we want to control and change
the politics it's not going to happen
from washington it's going to be a
decentralized movement and it kind of is
well that's that that's a great point uh
i think politics as we see it right now
is a facade
when you can't even go on
social media to the public square to the
water cooler and say here is my
political opinion
then there is no democracy there is no
democratic institution it's quite
literally
we've mentioned this before imagine it
this way
we get locked down
we're told we can't go to bars we can't
go to restaurants so no one's talking to
each other
how are we communicating on twitter what
is twitter doing twitter was censoring
news that that harmed joe biden's
campaign
so when you have the interests of a
private corporation saying we can
control what you see in here your
politics your vote completely
meaningless
there's there there could be large
swaths and there probably are of people
in this country with a very particular
political opinion and they're going to
be like oh i can't bring that up because
you know if i try i'll get censored so
i'll opt not to say it out of sight out
of mind there's that saying from harriet
tubman i believe it was harry tubman or
i believe it's a real could be
apocryphal i have freed many slaves i
would have freed many more if only they
knew they were slaves
if people don't know what they don't
know it just never comes up and so when
you see twitter censoring the hunter
biden story
that overtly benefited the biden
campaign so how can we say that we have
any kind of real political system if if
that's what we're living under and i i
agree with you you know giving the
government power is no guarantee it's
it's no it they're not going to solve it
right we could cross our fingers and be
like well what if we said okay you can
break up these companies they say okay
we'll break up all the enemies of
twitter so twitter becomes the dominant
company and you you look at what they do
to parlor what they do to gab the
government will just use their power to
benefit their their collaborators in the
private sector
right exactly and so i don't have a
great answer for okay well then what do
we do so
for sure though i just want to be clear
i'm not saying hey they're a private
company they do whatever they want like
that's not what i'm saying but i am
saying that let's be realistic partly
you know why these corporations do pose
a threat is because they're in league
with states that have you know armies
and prisons behind them and you know
monopoly printing presses so that's
you're not gonna like empowering one to
you know keep the others in check that's
certainly not uh a good solution
yeah so we'll probably have like a
starlink decentralized uh internet
that's runs parallel with this corporate
internet and then we'll be able to have
like decentralized finance the problem
is the military if the government
controls the military it's kind of like
we are the government so we give these
people authority to make commands for us
but we don't have to do that this stupid
this governor in new york that was like
i have signed paperwork to give myself
the power
no that's a particular statement ever
power is granted it
is not
going back to what you were saying tim
my friend um took a a picture on the new
york city subway i think i'm getting
this right and it was a three pain thing
you know it's from like the cdc or
something or the new york version of the
board of health and the first pain
showed two people talking without masks
on yeah i saw that and it said bad and
then the middle pain shuts off with mass
better and then the best was them
texting each other
and yeah to me that had nothing to do
with
transmission of a virus that had to do
with get people talking through the
thing that you're right they control the
flow of information i have uh i have
just written a decree granting myself
the power to declare ian must make me a
loaf of bread oh i thought you were
going keto but i can't i can't defy that
order
i'm not gonna eat the bread isn't that
insane
if you can just declare you have the
power to do it did you have the power to
do it the entire time that's how insane
this is they're voted into office to
represent us and can be voted out at any
moment
but they just might drop that's that's
the thing is the military the things the
military and satellite intervention if
they can watch you from above and see if
you're farming on your land and then
come in with military that's messed up
so where does this all lead to i mean
this is probably one of the most
pessimistic you know conversations we've
had in a while it's like
you know ian you make a good point about
there's like the politics is not what we
think it is yeah that's kind of just
distracting us i i feel like that's the
bread in the circus where it's like
who's gonna win the election whoo you
can pick of our approved candidates and
you get the republican who says well
wait a little bit the democrat says burn
it all down and then what happens is you
vote for the republicans and they go oh
okay we're going to resist we'll be
sleeping over there you get the democrat
and they're like great time to start
knocking stuff over so there's no real
resistance at all and i think that's why
they just absolutely despise marjory
taylor greene and lauren bobert not to
say that they're you know
changing the game either maybe they're
just louder voices but still not enough
to actually make it make a difference
here
right and i think that that explains
just the hostility to trump you know
whether people love him or hate him that
he was so out of the mainstream like he
actually was not playing the game
according to the standard rules like
normally the republicans like we're so
sorry we're so sexist and racist but
please you know give us a chance because
we're better on economics than them and
trump was not playing that game and was
going around and so that's why it was
just code red
establishment in both parties you know
national review had a whole issue
against trump i think people some people
forget that that
conservative inc was not pro-trump in
the beginning they didn't like him
either he was too much of a you know
wild card and whether he wasn't playing
the game that they had wanted to play
too so
uh and you know and i'm not
singing praises to trump i'm just saying
that you could see how the system is
what it is and they like that yep here's
two candidates and it's you know shade
of gray or a shade of gray this way
choose and now you're free because you
got to pick a person every four years
and to me yeah that's why now i i think
states breaking away or you know cities
or what have you is the only
near term to midterm way to do anything
it has to be super subtle because if
they think that you're breaking away
they'll come in with a boot but if you
just do it with parallel systems that's
synergize i think it can happen thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 p.m where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you